I hope you've taken your Dramamine
because this one's gonna be a doozy
no hi my name is grace Helbig if you
didn't know now you know your life is
different now yesterday I went on my
Instagram story the IG story and I asked
you guys for some video ideas and a
bunch of you wanted to hear my thoughts
on love is blind how nice I have so many
thoughts and today we're sharing them if
you don't know love is blind is a show
on Netflix that I was hesitant to get
into and then like all reality
television programming as soon as I
dipped my toe in the water some sort of
giant shark creature grabs it by the rag
and toenail and drags me all the way in
and somehow I'm me dipping my toe and
I'm also the shark creature pulling
myself in every time it happens for
those that haven't watched yet
congratulations on that freedom love is
blind is a dating reality show on
Netflix it poses this scientific
question experiment I notice I use
science loosely can you fall in love
with someone based solely on an
emotional connection without physically
seeing or interacting with that person
it's hosted by two of America's most
prominent scientists Nick and Vanessa
Lachey they take a group of guys a group
of girls they put them in these pod
situations they are exposed to nothing
else but each other's voices and then
they decide if they've created a strong
enough connection to get engaged their
obvious next step they get engaged they
get to see each other and then after
they see each other they go on a
honeymoon and then they live together
and then after like two months they have
a wedding and at the altar both
individually decide if they want to
marry each other
romance is one thing but when you take
science and you put it into that romance
you're gonna get a reaction and I
watched every second of it and now here
are my thoughts about all of the main
players in this game
I mean experiment look I've been writing
all of my thoughts and down on paper
like I'm doing an actual thing like
science fair project I know I'll have so
many more thoughts after I shoot this
video I know that there's a reunion
happening so I wanted to put this out
before I see the reunion I have to
preface this with saying no
offense to any of kudos to them for
putting themselves out on a reality
program like this of this nature and
having to endure all of just the Shh
that comes with putting yourself out
there in any capacity let alone in a
dating capacity under the microscope of
the rest of society because the rest of
society you know we're all perfect so
they're not this is our chance to really
project our own insecurities onto all
these people that are genuinely putting
themselves out there in the hope of love
where do I begin I have so many notes
let's start with amber amber Wow
she is a lot in a lot you know look
there's a little wind-up dog toys that
they have in the front of toy stores
that's just like run in place and then
backflip and then run in place then
backflip and then run in place and
backflip I feel like that's her in every
one of her talking head interviews her
facial expressions slow my mind she's
like those theater masks that are happy
and sad but like in one face happening
all the time at the same time it's like
her mouth and her eyes move
independently of each other and they're
creating every spectrum of emotional
range all at the same time she has a
strong personality I think she's also
very strong physically she said her eyes
on Barnett and she claimed him like if
they were allowed to be in the same pod
I feel like she would have pissed all
over him was fascinated watching this
woman just as a very curious way of
claiming someone that she loves by
basically saying over and over again
that she will cause him some sort of
physical harm if they ever even think
about leaving her she was like I love
you so much
if you leave me I hope physically harm
you I've done it before I know this
sounds like a cute metaphor but it's
like very real you're my best friend
at first I thought she might be a little
bonkers I didn't totally trust that she
was on a show like this for the right
reason like every single person that's
on a show like this and I started to
believe in how much she believed in her
love for Barnet I'm a wildly indecisive
person so I envy your ability to make
aggressive decisions and to chase goals
with such aggression but she did get
into a situation with Barnett where she
wanted to make sure that if his family
had differing opinions than she did on
situations including like their
relationship that she went to Barnett to
take her side and not his family side
because in her mind blood is not always
thicker than water and I would just like
to challenge a little bit of this
practical science behind that also I
don't want to offend her in any way
shape or form because I like my nose and
I need it let's talk about Barnett
Barnett is like every guy I went to high
school with smashed into one person like
he's for sure not ironically worn double
pop collars in his life at some point
he's like if someone tailgated the
opening of an Abercrombie & Fitch at the
mall but then sometimes he has these
like sensitive moments and he cries
about his actions and his inability to
treat women with respect like as weird
Freaky Friday where he's like a feminist
trapped in like this kind of toxic
masculinity body and that's fun to watch
it's fun to watch inner turmoil if see
the real-life version of the movie what
women want I never saw that movie and
then it's fascinating to watch him when
he realizes that he's committed himself
to marry a woman who slays literally she
may have slain a human in her past we
don't know he also must have grown up
playing football because he plays a
strong defense against Jessica
the whole season I am fascinated to see
if they ended up staying together
because also I found out that this show
I actually filmed back in like 2018 the
reunions gonna bring a lot of it to life
moving on Kelly and Kenny Kelly and
Kenny are a little boring
I think boring only because they're
slightly more normal they're like
watching two choir kids date each other
they're like two kids that got cast as
the leads in the spring musical and
they're like actually starting to date
off stage and all of the stage hands
they're just like fascinated and jealous
of their love they're also just like two
Cuban politically correct blobs that
just kind of hang out with each other
there's not a lot of drama there other
than the fact that Kelly just slowly
over the course
season reveals that she's not actually
attracted to Kenny and everyone around
them like their family their friends are
just like good a non-problematic it's
like if pottery barn was a group of
humans also sorry for spoilers I'm not
sorry this shows been out you've had
time to do your thing and at the end
when she tells Kenny that she can't
marry him it's like I could feel the
collective quaking of the rest of the
cast of Jesus Christ Superstar opening
night is in two weeks
how are they gonna do this Jesus can't
sexually satisfy Mary Magdalene what are
they gonna do and the understudies are
backstage like oh all I can say is
there's gonna be drama at that cast
party this year
when she said no and then walk down the
aisle with her sister just like proud
and awkward it was all just so confusing
I feel bad for Kenny Kenny didn't see it
coming literally South Park and love is
blind
Kenny's can't catch a break let's talk
about Giannina and Damian who first of
all Giannina only speaks in riddles she
only speaks in riddles REE watch it tell
me I'm wrong I loved every second of it
the way that they communicate with each
other is like watching two actors in
like a very amateur scene study class
perform if they think that they're doing
like oscar-worthy performances it's just
so much not only doesn't G Nina talking
riddles
she also talks like she's solving a
murder mystery so you liked me in the
pods based on my voice we get out of the
pods and we move in together and we
start to get a physical connection with
each other but then all of a sudden you
don't like me anymore and I'm left here
by myself in the kitchen with the knife
I love it I think it's so fun and so
interesting also I hope Giannina never
gets a dog because she can't even keep
her butterflies but when you pair her
with Damian oh it's just such a
fascinating thing to watch because he
looks like an IT guy but he talks like a
Shakespearean actor in the middle of
being poisonous everything is this
emotionally aggressive thing that he can
barely get out through his lips and he's
trying to choke it back down his throat
it's like he's got to tell so heart
beating in his head all day every day
long especially when he was at the
and he ended up telling Giannina that he
couldn't marry her him trying to get out
the know was just so much face the
emotional angst and trauma that was just
surging through his face made him look
like someone was forcing him to watch
like two girls one cup without throwing
those editors probably were just like oh
this is gold but then Giannina got both
fairytale fantasies at the end do you
have to say these like kind of
poetically weird vows to Damian and then
he broke her heart and she got to play
runaway bride and girls got some gams
she ran in heels in the mud she slipped
it was so Oh God it's like I could see
Candace Cameron Bure playing Giannina in
the Lifetime movie version based on this
show and then she got to tie it up like
a perfect one-act play by ripping off
the bottom of her dress and tying it
back on his hand the way he tied that
weird-ass bow and told her that he was
her gift it's all very confusing
there are metaphors in the riddles it
creates these verbal escape rooms that I
get stuck in I don't know how to get out
of them and I love it okay we have to
move on to Jessica and Mark the ones
that I probably have the most to say
about Jessica is on everyone's radar in
this show I know she is so interesting
to watch she's got big every single
contestant that's ever been on The
Bachelor in the history of The Bachelor
smashed together energy and I'm sure she
hates watching herself on this show and
hates the way that she comes across on
this show which is why I feel for her
for it's like putting herself out there
she also has all of these like
contradictory feelings about what she's
doing on the show you can tell that
she's trying to preemptively like
circumvent navigate the way they're
gonna edit her who the tension of her
trying to be likable but also trying to
be honest is hidden doors all there are
many favors because she knew she was
leading this guy out in the beginning
and she was trying to get there I guess
but it's just so obvious and I know when
you're in it you're probably it's so
different than when you're watching it
it's like a mucky little swamp that I
don't mind like just waiting around and
it's gross she's the kind of girl
that'll be like I'm a vegetarian
I don't like animal cruelty and then
someone
like you know Brad Pitt's favorite food
is chicken fingers and you cut back to
her and she's like on a farm snapping
chicken necks
it's very motivated by what people think
you'd have like a pickle back shot and
then you'd be like two plus two equals
four and she'll be like how can you even
say that
you can't call to stews what if they
want to be ones and that's not how it
works
no two plus two equals four that's so
rude
oh my how dare you my dog get another
glass of Pinot I feel like she caught
herself being honest sometimes and had
to backtrack but she'd be like the
thought of sleeping with someone that's
ten years younger than me that I'm not
at all physically attracted to is like a
question that some people will probably
have to confront in this experiment ah
not me though because I I'm I'm here to
find real love like Mark he checks all
of the boxes except the one at the top
because he's just too shortening can't
reach it oh I feel like a lot of what
she was saying was like yes he is
emotionally very intelligent yes he is
very psychologically mature and yes
every time I look at him he reminds me
of the youth that I once have that is
slipping away out of my control and thus
I hate him directly for it even though
it's not his fault in any capacity but I
do for Jeff my insecurities onto him
directly because I don't want to UM and
he's got roommates so like whoa kind of
a deal breaker
we'll see you know um it's Burnett doing
his talking head after me like well he
is he here
is it I thought I heard I smelled I I
can with that I was wait it's easy to
hate on her but she put herself into
this situation and this situation is so
bizarre I'm curious to see what sort of
humble pie is she'll be eating at
reunion because it's very trendy to own
your mistakes then we have mark
god bless mark it was ten years younger
than Jeff
still 10 years younger than Jessica and
oh you seem like a sweet guy that
thought he caught himself a babe and
didn't want to throw her back by any
means and you can't fault him for
wanting that he was blinded by his own
infatuation with a hot blonde and he
couldn't see that she made falling in
love with her like this weird fraternity
hazing so did you and just gonna get
intimate last night oh yeah yeah it was
oh man we sit up like so late like
getting to know each other just talking
like she really wanted to get to know me
like she took my phone like look through
all my social media and then like ask me
for my tax returns for the last two
years and then actually took a urine
sample and then have me like chug a
whole bottle of Jagermeister and do like
a hundred push-ups Wow she like
repeatedly had me say like I'm a little
[ __ ] boy it was cool cuz the whole time
had a bag on my head she was like a pod
and then we both just like got tired so
I had to sleep naked on the couch and
she got to sleep in the bed and like I
definitely heard her masturbating in the
Barnett's Instagram but like you know
that anything can happen in the pods so
my mom likes her you get so I'm just
we're playing we're goofing I feel free
mark I think he's gonna come out on top
I think there's gonna be a lot of women
that saw him on the show that are very
attractive to him he won't have any
shortage of pleasure and then you've
Lauren and Cameron they're great I can't
wait to see if they've stayed together I
hope so I will say about Lauren I've
never seen someone emulate this face
emoji almost the entire time I loved it
okay I could probably talk for two more
hours
about all of this but those are just my
thoughts on the people from love is
blind I like the show very much I hope
it comes back for another season I'm
curious to see how people play with the
experiment let me know in the comments
down below what you guys thought of it
if you watched it subscribe to this
YouTube channel if you have it I make
videos
than that I don't know oh my god I
forgot I love mark oh you think we're
the Priyanka and Nick oh my god don't
even stop saying that ever only say that
to me forever
please I did I did say that I love when
an older woman loves a younger guy I did
say that didn't I I said that and you
believed that too and that means I
believe it too things are going well I'm
sorry if I offended anyone